in the past almost everybody was
desperately poor in 1800 80% of the
world's population lived on the
equivalent of less than $2 a day the
productivity Revolution is what ended
that Adam Smith says near the end of The
Wealth of Nations that the only purpose
of production is consumption and in a
world in which almost everybody is
desperately poor that principle has a
kind of a grim moral logic when you work
to make things that other people need
you relieve dire dire needs second point
though is that at some point of every
good and even money more no longer makes
us better off more and more production
is harming the planet in a variety of
ways and harming our society what is the
point of production when Smith's Mantra
has outlived its usefulness when we have
enough or even too much consumption and
how should we structure our work lives
so that work is not a technology to
productivity but a process that is
valuable in
[Music]
itself